madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je voulais vous dire que c'est
avec émotion une émotion vive que nous
avons appris la mort dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche à crépole dans
laadrome d'un adolescent de 16 ans
Thomas décédé des suite d'un coup de
couteau reçu alors qu'il participait à
un bal jeis
simplement nous associons par la pensée
à la marche organisé cet après-midi à
roman sur iser pour lui rendre hommage
au nom du Sénat j'assure de notre
profonde sympathie sa famille ses
proches les élus municipaux de crépul
que je sais particulièrement atteint et
l'ensemble des victimes blessées cette
nuit-là dans des circonstances qu'il
appartiendra à la justice de
déterminer